[Musique]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur le plateau dès maintenant
l'émission qui revient avec plaisir et
avec vous sur l'actualité politique de
la semaine vous connaissez le principe
# et maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau nous avons
des professionnels ils ont les infos et
le recul ils ont l'art et la manière ils
sont très intelligents je vous présente
mes invités Ghislaine Ottenheimer
bonjour ça va editorial
président du cabinet de conseils et là
merci d'être avec nous Alexandra
schwarzbroot bonjour vous êtes
directrice adjoint de la rédaction de
Libération vous êtes aussi romancière je
signale votre livre lumière de Tel-Aviv
c'est publié aux éditions rivage et
Pascal Perino bonjour bonjour professeur
des universités à Sciences Po Paris je
renvoie à votre dernière ouvrage le
populisme c'est à retrouver au puce
merci d'être là dans cette émission on
se demandera si le métier d'homme
politique fait encore rêver on se
demandera ici en France l'énergie
nucléaire fait désormais consensus sont
se rendra aux États-Unis ou une fois
encore un jeune noir et mort après une
interpellation de la police on ira enfin
au Sénégal ou Marine Le Pen a dit je
t'aime à tout le continent africain mais
d'abord merci président Larcher cette
mobilisation massive dans les rues
contre la réforme des retraites plus de
2 millions de manifestants au marché
jeudi selon la CGT ils étaient plus d'un
million selon la police il s'agissait
quoi qu'il en soit d'une mobilisation
très importante écoutez il y a beaucoup
de monde c'est même une surprise et même
dans mon entreprise il y a beaucoup de
salariés qui se sont mis en grève c'est
ce qui prouve que cette réforme est
vraiment très très injuste il est hors
de question qu'on continue à travailler
beaucoup plus longtemps que ce qui est
prévu initialement parce que on a des
conditions de travail qui sont
absolument déplorables on est usé
physiquement donc je suis facteur à vélo
même si on a des vélos électriques à
assistance électrique je bois pas
jusqu'à 67 ans sur un vélo en train de
de pédaler et en plus à la poste il y a
des réformes structurelles tout le temps
plus cette réforme de retraite déjà ça
me coupe les jambes donc pour pédaler
avoir les jambes coupées c'est pas idéal
Alexandra qu'est-ce que cette
mobilisation réussie visiblement va
changer à au projet du gouvernement
alors sur tout ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut bien voir c'est que je pense que la
réforme des retraites est en effet un
sujet qui préoccupe tout le monde et
elle est refusée massivement il est
refusé massivement ce projet mais il n'y
a pas que ça s'il y avait autant de
monde dans la rue hier c'est que je
crois qu'il y a une il y a une espèce de
cette espèce de déni de ce que veut la
population française est de et de mépris
justement de ce que veut la population
française ou de ce qu'elle ne veut pas
je crois insupporte de plus en plus les
gens et si tout le monde est descendu
dans la rue hier je dis tout le monde
parce qu'on a bien vu qu'il y avait des
syndiqués dénon syndiqués des jeunes des
vieux des retraités même des retraités
et donc c'est que ça va encore au-delà
du refus de cette ce projet de réforme
des retraites et ma question c'est
est-ce que cette mobilisation qui peut
aller on verra crescendo peut faire
d'une certaine manière plier le
gouvernement est-ce que la rue peut
gagner contre le gouvernement Pascal
la rue peut gagner l'a déjà gagné dans
le passé 1995 la rue gagne contre le
gouvernement
mais quand vous regardez la litanie des
réformes depuis le début des années 90
la première réforme Balladur vous vous
apercevez qu'il y a toujours eu la
situation qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que il y a à chaque fois
une mobilisation qui au départ est une
mobilisation vigoureuse le 1 million et
quelques selon les chiffres de la police
ont là déjà connu avec la réforme Fillon
avec la réforme verte donc on connaît ça
le problème c'est qu'il est trop tôt
pour dire est-ce que véritablement ça va
s'amplifier ça va s'élargir et ça va
durer et là il faut bien avoir en tête
un double calendrier le calendrier du
mouvement social après ça comme ça et
puis le câlin janvier
parce que là si vous voulez la réforme
peut s'accélérer à l'Assemblée nationale
et qu'on le veuille ou non à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a une majorité pour voter
cette réforme et donc ensuite comment
réagirait éventuellement le mouvement
social une fois acté la réforme à
l'Assemblée nationale là c'est très
difficile de l'estimer de l'estime
aujourd'hui mais il peut y avoir comme
il y a eu dans le passé après un
étiolement de ce mouvement social ça a
été le cas après la réforme Fillon ça a
été le cas juste après la réforme parce
que j'aimerais vous montrer quelque
chose on vous a préparé une petite
infographie avec un coup d'œil sur les
dernières réformes des retraites 1995
plan Juppé vous en parliez Pascal 2
millions de personnes dans la rue grève
de trois semaines la réforme est donc
retirée 2003 on va voir réforme Fillon
2000 ans de personnes dans la rue des
grèves dans la fonction publique mais
mais la loi est adoptée le 24 juillet et
puis effectivement 2010 la réforme woert
Sarkozy Fillon qui décale l'âge de de
départ à la retraite de 60 à 2 ans 14
journées de mobilisation entre un les 3
millions de personnes dans la rue la loi
est finalement adoptée le 9 novembre
Ghislaine question peut-être un peu
provocatrice est-ce que ça sert encore
aujourd'hui de descendre de se mobiliser
contre une réforme des retraites
je pense que la démonstration était
faite que ça peut servir parce que
l'histoire n'est pas écrite ce que je
veux dire c'est que Emmanuel Macron
justement c'est basé sur les chiffres
que vous avez donné pour dire finalement
on finit toujours par gagner et il l'a
fait avec la réforme du statut de la
SNCF où il y a eu une grève dure et ils
ont quand même réussi à faire passer
leur réforme l'idée est que finalement
quand l'exécutif a les manettes il peut
faire ce qu'il veut et bah ça pour voilà
d'autant plus que les syndicats se sont
effrités les mobilisations sont
scientifiques donc il s'est dit qu'ils
se sont dit que finalement ils pouvaient
passer sans trop de difficultés sauf que
moi je vois ce qui s'est passé hier je
pense que il y a un basculement dans
l'opinion publique je suis assez
d'accord avec Alexandra il y a une
espèce de ras-le-bol de ce côté
autocratique du pouvoir l'impression que
finalement il y a juste une petite caste
qui décide et de réformes en réforme que
ce soit l'assurance chômage que ce soit
le statut de la SNCF et puis il y a eu
le covid ils ont une marque on leur
impose un certain nombre de choses sans
que ce soit forcément le rapport mais la
situation locale donc il y a une espèce
de ras-le-bol du pouvoir là-haut et
l'envie de démontrer que il faut les
entendre alors là jusqu'où ça peut aller
je suis d'accord avec Pascal Perrineau
c'est très compliqué parce qu'ils vont
jouer la vitesse à l'Elysée ils vont ils
vont essayer de faire passer ça assez
vite si les républicains tiennent bon et
continuer à voter parce qu'ils peuvent
aussi être impressionnés par ce qui se
passe dans leur circonscription et dans
ce qui se passe à la semaine mais moi
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on se concentre
sur la rue
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a quand même
un espèce de remobilisation et qui a un
bras de fer sur ses 64 ans et je pense
que ça va pas ça va pas s'arrêter tout
de suite maintenant voilà c'est on peut
pas prédire l'avenir Bernard si on
regarde effectivement l'évolution et
cette petite historique que je vous ai
proposé est-ce que finalement les
mouvements sociaux ne par plus à faire
plier les gouvernements j'allais dire et
je rejoins un peu ce qui a été si il n'y
avait que la réforme des retraites ce
serait une opposition normale quand
monsieur Charpin vient présenter la
réforme marocain en 91 rocardie il y a
de quoi faire sauter plusieurs
gouvernements donc on sait les réformes
des retraites sont un populaire et c'est
vrai parce qu'elle l'a rappelé le niveau
de mobilisation et pour l'instant
semblable peut-être légèrement supérieur
d'ailleurs il semble être plus plus
important dans les villes moyennes par
rapport à d'habitude ça c'est à suivre
mais s'il n'y avait que ça finalement
sur une mobilisation normale mais il y a
deux éléments qui viennent impacter plus
largement le contexte le premier c'est
l'inflation l'inflation qui déclenche
deux types de réactions la première on
le voit dans nos études une partie de
gens qui disent finalement ce n'était
pas le moment alors il y a jamais de bon
moment mais il y en a des plus mauvais
que d'autres et la deuxième qui est la
théorie un peu de la goutte d'eau c'est
à dire c'est déjà c'est tellement
difficile que en plus je cite des des
phrases lues dans les études vous nous
en rajoutez encore quelque chose de
difficile premièrement et le deuxième
c'est une tendance de fond il en a
évoqué à l'instant c'est les évolutions
de la société post covid et on voit bien
que le rapport au travail a profondément
changé le travailler plus le travail est
plus longtemps ne sont plus aujourd'hui
des des moteurs dans la société et si le
mouvement syndical arrive à élargir son
ses motifs à ces questions-là si
j'allais dire si finalement il dépasse
la question des retraites pour aller sur
la question du travail du partage de la
valeur etc à ce moment-là il peut donner
un souffle assez fort en mouvement vous
connaissez le cabinet d'études et Lab
oui vous êtes évidemment le patron du
cabinet là on va voir le sondage que
vous avez sorti le 18 janvier pour BFM
TV 66% des Français se disent opposés à
la réforme des retraites telles qu'elles
a été annoncée par Elisabeth borne de
son côté Emmanuel Macron vous allez
l'entendre reste droit dans ses bottes
depuis l'Espagne où il était en
déplacement il a de nouveau justifié la
nécessité de cette réforme écoutez
temps de la proposition du gouvernement
elle va donner lieu à un travail
démocratique parlementaire qui permettra
à toutes les forces politiques à
l'Assemblée au Sénat de s'exprimer
d'enrichir le projet et de pouvoir aller
au terme d'une réforme qui est une
réforme qui a donc été démocratiquement
présentée validé
qui est une réforme sur tout juste et
responsable bon Alexandra Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas l'air d'avoir très peur
des manifestants mais c'est ça il est là
le drame c'est que Emmanuel Macron ne
comprend pas est en train de passer à
côté de ce qui est en train de se passer
il est dans sa bulle dans son obsession
de laisser une réforme à son crédit
après son départ et il ne comprend pas
ce qui se passe il est quand il dit ça a
été validé par l'élection si en gros si
on m'a élu c'est parce que on était
d'accord avec ce que je voulais faire
non là encore une fois il est totalement
à côté de la plaque il a été élu parce
que la gauche massivement est allée
voter pour lui pour éviter Marine Le Pen
et mais pas du tout pour son programme
et ça s'il ne comprend pas ça c'est
grave et je suis d'accord aussi avec
Bernard sananas sur son explication sur
le le la valeur travail qui est en train
de changer on l'a bien vu depuis le
covid on le voit bien tous autour de
nous les gens n'ont plus envie du tout
de passer leur vie travailler ils
veulent une autre façon de travailler
une autre façon de vivre de profiter de
leur vie personnelle même les bêtes de
travail ont envie de profiter de leur
vie personnelle et ça si vous voulez il
est il est dans l'inverse il fait
l'inverse il passe totalement à côté et
juste une dernière chose qu'est-ce qui
se passera même si la réforme des
retraites passe le drame c'est que ça va
miner les fondements de la société
française et ça peut péter très vite tôt
ou tard dans les mois ou les dans les
mois qui viennent sur avec une autre
occasion
je crois que la nécessité en effet
d'élargir de dépasser le stricte
problème des retraites pour aborder la
question du travail est essentielle
parce que en effet
la période de la covid a changé les
choses dans le rapport que les Français
ont avec le travail même si comment dire
l'attachement des Français à la retraite
et bien antérieure à cette affaire de de
la COV quelque chose en effet à changer
et si le front syndical arrive à élargir
pour reprendre le jargon le chant des
luttes en effet il peut y avoir une
fenêtre d'opportunité pour eux mais
quand on regarde en particulier
l'enquête
l'enquête dont vous venez parler moi ce
qui me
frappe aussi c'est quand même dans
certes plus de voilà de environ deux
Français sur trois sont opposés à cette
réforme bon ce qu'on appelle ces grèves
d'opinion là aussi c'est pas nouveau
c'est pas nouveau mais en même temps
dans l'enquête on s'aperçoit qu'une
majorité de Français disent mais toute
façon la réforme elle aura lieu comme
mais comment vous expliquer ce paradoxe
on est contre mais on n'est pas non plus
farouchement compte quand vous regardez
le noyau qui est véritablement opposé je
parle sous ton contrôle Bernard c'est
quoi environ 40% voilà 40% et d'autre
part il y a un volant environ de 33% de
Français qui sont favorables à réforme
donc tout ça pour dire que ça peut
évoluer parce que imaginez que voilà
fort du succès de la mobilisation d'hier
les grèves s'étendent qu'on rajoute à la
difficulté de la vie quotidienne la
difficulté du transport la difficulté de
faire garder ses enfants dans une école
publique qui est en grève là vous pouvez
avoir un phénomène d'usure de l'opinion
et comment vous expliquer aussi voilà
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
Pascal comment vous expliquer ce
paradoxe des Français effectivement
opposés à cette réforme mais qui disent
bon bah finalement ça passera quoi qu'il
arrive Bernard on a vu on a vu la
succession des réformes avec les
mouvements sociaux et puis ça continuait
quand même les réformes passées moi je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord sur le
fait que ce soit la valeur travail le
covid qui soit le moteur de cette
mobilisation c'est certes vrai que quand
on vous dit vous allez travailler pour
plus longtemps pour pas plus d'argent
ça ne fait plaisir à personne
c'est pas gratos quoi voilà on est pas
du tout content moi je pense qu'une des
choses qui est à mobilise beaucoup les
gens c'est l'injustice c'est le
sentiment il y a eu des erreurs
magistrales dans la présentation de la
réforme qu'on a commencé à dire ça ne va
pas cette réforme elle va servir à
financer l'école alors tout d'un coup
déjà on avait une réforme contre
l'assurance maladie puis après on a une
réforme contre pour les retraites et
tout ça parce qu'il y a des déficits
publics mais on parle là de 25 ou 30
milliards dans quelques années alors que
là il y a 160 milliards de déficits
commerciales à 160 milliards de dettes
il y a bon il y a un moment de
communication non mais il y a un moment
les gens ils disent mais il faudrait
peut-être voir où est-ce qu'il y a des
trous où est-ce qu'il y a des fuites
est-ce que le plus important c'est nous
avec les retraités attendez on est on a
on a une cette année c'est excédentaire
l'année prochaine aussi bon vraiment il
y a peut-être d'autres urgences sur
l'ordi c'est urgent c'est urgent faisait
pêcher parce que voilà il y a le feu au
lac mais non mais regardez un peu ce qui
se passe ailleurs il y a des fuites
partout pourquoi est-ce que c'est chez
nous et le sentiment qu'effectivement
depuis des années on n'a pas arrêté dans
ce pays de dire c'est très dur pour les
riches c'est très pour les entreprises
sauf que depuis il y a eu la loi du
travail on peut transmettre son
entreprise gratuitement il y a eu la
flat tax pour les dividendes enfin il y
a eu beaucoup de choses qui ont été
faites pour finalement les investisseurs
les entreprises et les salariés
commencent à dire ras-le-bol et je pense
que c'est c'est aussi l'injustice le
sentiment d'injustice qui fait sortir
les gens dans la rue le fait qu'on leur
demande de traduire actuellement
l'avenir de son second mandat au début
de ce mandat on peut pas faire beaucoup
de plans à moyen terme mais c'est un
enjeu majeur pour lui non pas tant
d'ailleurs que la réforme des retraites
soit encore un totem comme on l'a
souvent dit dans son électorat ou dans
l'électoral de droite elle craintes
évidemment la volonté réformatrice mais
comme la dynane il y a d'autres
priorités par exemple le sujet qui
au-delà du pouvoir d'achat s'installe
comme une préoccupation majeure des
Français depuis plusieurs mois c'est la
question du système de santé sujet sur
lequel en plus il y a eu cette confusion
de finalement à quoi ça va servir mais
c'est vrai que dans la première semaine
le gouvernement a perdu deux batailles
en terme de communication non c'est
jamais facile de mener une campagne sur
la forme de retraite le premier c'est la
campagne de l'argument de la nécessité
la réforme nécessaire la semaine
dernière avant que le Gouvernement
présente son projet enfin jusqu'en
madame borne a présenté on était
quasiment égalité nécessaire pas
nécessaire ça recule de 8 points une
semaine donc tous les débats sur les
chiffres du corps finalement est-ce que
la situation est grave là le
gouvernement n'a pas marqué de points et
le deuxième évidemment c'est celui de la
justice avec le sentiment que la réforme
va d'abord impacter les plus modestes on
le sait dans la société française la
revendication de justice est une
revendication majeure vous avez près du
Français sur 10 qui considère que la
société est injuste et donc ils peuvent
avoir le sentiment que la réforme va
aggraver l'injustice et dernier point la
contradiction apparente entre ça va
passer pourquoi à mon avis une partie de
l'opinion dit ça va passer parce que ils
écoutent les médias les informations ils
savent qu'il y a le 49-3 ils savent
qu'il y a un accord possible avec LR
donc par contre il se disent la seule
solution possible pour plus d'un
Français sur deux ça peut être les
blocages et pour l'instant il ne
désapprouve pas l'idée je rejoins Pascal
si ça avait lieu évidemment ça peut
changer justement ou parler de 4
j'aimerais avoir votre éclairage Pascal
sur ce point alors là c'est vapète ça va
pas passer par un 49,3 ce sera un 47 1
le projet loi donc sera présenté lundi
en conseil des ministres expliquez-nous
la spécificité un peu de cette procédure
constitutionnelle 49-3 c'est faire
passer sans qu'il y ait un vote un texte
en disant écoutez si vous osez
faites-nous tomber quoi
là il s'agit de dégager autour de ce
projet une majorité et je crois qu'il y
a une majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
si vous voulez vous prenez la majorité
horizon les marcheurs etc même s'il y a
quelques contestations mais on pourra
leur accorder dans le débat
parlementaire quelques concessions vous
prenez LR LR je crois qu'il y aura
peut-être la défection quoi aller d'une
dizaine de députés mais pas plus besoin
de 49,3 pas besoin de 49 mais le
gouvernement encadre quand même le temps
de débat sur le gouvernement encadre le
temps de déb parce que en effet il y a
une question d'agenda et de vitesse
le pouvoir public qui le pouvoir
politique qui met en place cette réforme
à lui son agenda et donc c'est une
course de vitesse et pendant ce temps-là
justement pendant ce temps-là marine le
Penet au Sénégal oui loin des pavés la
député du RN a quitté la France lundi
pour un voyage de trois jours en Afrique
pas grand chose n'a filtré de cette
visite enfin si ça regardez
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on avait c'est
les images du journaliste du point
Charles sapin juste peut-être question
au timing Marine Le Pen n'est pas là
alors qu'un mouvement social est en
train de s'organiser en France comment
vous l'interprétez vous Alexandre
puisque Emmanuel Macron non plus n'était
pas là pour un conseil franco-espagnol
là on est on est très clairement dans la
dans les dans la politique de
normalisation qu'à entreprise Marine Le
Pen puisque évidemment le président de
la République
émettre de deux domaines régaliens les
affaires étrangères et la défense donc
là elle sait qu'elle doit bosser cette
cette stature là et surtout qu'elle doit
essayer de se défaire de son image de
personnalité
des dictateurs ou en tout cas de ceux
qui mènent des politiques il libérales
comme Victor Orban ou Vladimir Poutine
et donc elle essaye de gommer cette
image là elle a rencontré à côté de
cette mobilisation contre la réforme de
retraite c'est que pourtant son
électorat soutient très largement
l'opposition à la réforme et soutenu
quasiment dans les mêmes proportions
légèrement moins par les électeurs RN
que les électeurs de la France insoumise
les différents mouvements mobilisations
un peu moins parce que c'est vrai que la
culture de la Grèce de manifestation
appartient moins électeurs du
rassemblement national mais c'est vrai
que c'est surprenant qu'elle ne cherche
pas ça fait comme si finalement elle
aussi avait déjà conclu que la réforme
allait passer et qu'elle voulait plutôt
engranger le mécontentement la
popularité de la réforme pour ceux qui
sera elle sa grande bataille
c'est-à-dire l'élection présidentielle
de 2027 est-ce qu'elle peut être se
présenter comme la première opposante
Emmanuel Macron la première représente
sur ce thème des retraites sans je sais
pas pas forcément aller dans la rue mais
faire des sorties dans les médias
expliquer sa position
sauf que hier la journée ne sera ne peut
pas être mise au crédit de Marine Le Pen
elle est mis au crédit des syndicats
donc elle en a rien à retirer de cette
journée d'action qui a été très régie
donc elle avait les opposants sont dans
la rue elle n'y est pas les marrons du
feu donc ça n'a aucune importance en
revanche avec en revanche elle veut
surplomber ça et c'est double c'est
double objectif c'est 1 évidemment ce
crédibiliser ce normalisé en disant
voilà moi je te vois des chefs d'État
étrangers et pas seulement la vie émir
courtine et voilà et en même temps elles
m'ont envoyé je suis pas raciste je
parle avec des Noirs etc mais derrière
il y a aussi il faut développer
l'Afrique pour pas qu'il vienne chez
nous voilà donc voilà c'est elle
craintes c'est vraiment c'est position
c'est c'est clair comme de l'eau de
roche c'est de la comme formidable de
l'Afrique mais juste Pascal sur sur
cette sur le rapport de Marine Le Pen au
mouvement social la manifester c'est pas
dans dans l'ADN du rassemblement
national en effet le mouvement social
défilé avec un front uni des syndicats
et la CGT SUD vous voyez c'est vraiment
pas la tasse de C la tasse de thé du
rassemblement national et de la famille
que ça représente mais enfin et la
présenter le projet comme étant une
escroquerie vous voyez pas aller par
contre si je mens pour elle la réforme
borne c'est une véritable escroquerie et
quand on l'a interrogé elle a dit voilà
si les électeurs du RN veulent
participer aux manifestations qu'ils y
aille mais il y aura pas d'appel du
rassemblement national à cette forme de
protestation qui n'est pas la leur elle
préfère elle la protestation par les
urnes et l'urgence pour elle c'est de se
gouvernementaliser et quelque part elle
a anticipé elle se trompe peut-être mais
l'anticiper que la reine dans lequel ça
va se décider c'est l'Assemblée
nationale et là certainement que dans le
débat l'Assemblée nationale elle sera
présente elle fera des propositions elle
participera au débat au débat
démocratique mais quelque part elle son
agenda c'est véritablement c'est à
l'Assemblée nationale que se passe et
que se passera que ça se passera et je
resterai ce qu'elle est dans les
sondages aujourd'hui la première
opposante parce que quand vous regardez
sur les six derniers mois ce qui est
frappant c'est que l'étoile du patron de
la France insoumise à cessé de décliner
et que pour les Français qui est la
femme qui représente aujourd'hui les
oppositions c'est Marine Le Pen vous
n'êtes pas raisonnable s'opposant
effectivement à Emmanuel Macron
peut-être sur le dossier international
on va voir la tribune publiée par Marine
Le Pen dans le journal l'opinion juste
avant de partir effectivement au Sénégal
pour améliorer la stabilité du monde il
faut cesser de dénier à l'Afrique la
place légitime qui doit lui revenir dans
l'organisation de la communauté
internationale il m'a apparaît évident
qu'un représentant de l'Afrique doit
siéger comme membre permanent du Conseil
de sécurité je pense que le Sénégal
pourrait assumer cette charge si
particulièrement
elle essaie de s'opposer à Emmanuel
Macron sur un point sur un sujet
l'international qui lui faisait un peu
défaut ces dernières années totalement
elle était on se souvient même de
c'était Donald Trump qu'elle était allé
voir qui avait refusé de la de la
vie il y avait cette image où on la
voyait dans une espèce de lobby en
attendant désespérément qu'il l'appelle
enfin bref ça plus c'est visites ces
valses deviennent avec avec tout ce que
l'Europe compte de d'extrême droite donc
ça voilà elle a compris qu'il fallait
qu'elle gomme cette image là si elle
voulait un jour accéder au pouvoir et je
pense qu'il faut faire très attention à
à ce qui est en train de faire Marine Le
Pen parce que elle est en train
d'engranger tout doucement elle a pas
besoin elle a pas besoin d'aller de
descendre dans la rue elle elle engrange
tout doucement tous les tous les
mécontentement dont on vient que l'on
vient d'évoquer et qui sont énormes et
qui sont
rien faire
elle n'a pas besoin et à l'Assemblée
nationale contrairement à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a fait à mon avis cette
erreur de pas se représenter elle l'a
elle a une tribune elle a elle elle peut
elle peut parler de cette tribune et ça
c'est un ça c'est malheureusement c'est
malheureusement très fort il y a quelque
chose de très frappant c'est que il y a
un certain nombre d'électeurs de droite
pour le moment n'ont pas franchi la
ligne jaune d'aller voter pour l'extrême
droite qui commence à dire oui ils sont
pas prêts ils savent pas gouverner mais
après tout c'était la même chose avec
François Mitterrand 80 il y a eu les
hauts fonctionnaires et l'État
finalement
il avait eu d'autres responsabilités
je dis simplement que si dans la tête
des gens c'est ça c'est finalement c'est
pas si grand danger que ça alors
qu'il y a quelques années bon c'était
c'était certain si l'extrême droite est
allé au pouvoir c'était le bordel total
on sortait de l'Europe c'était la fin de
tout etc là les jeudi on sort pas de
l'Europe il y a finalement des hauts
fonctionnaires qui tiennent le truc qui
sont quand même quelques députés à
l'Assemblée nationale qui ont réussi à
faire à peu près le job donc la peur de
Marine Le Pen est en train de tomber
c'est ça qui fait que ça change beaucoup
la donne
en Afrique ça lui permet effectivement
de crédibiliser aussi un petit peu plus
Bernard oui mais la crédibilisation
n'est pas le enfin et le seul enjeu mais
il y a la sphère internationale qui
évidemment c'est la présidentialisation
il y a la crédibilisation et là il y
aura quand même un rendez-vous au
Parlement parce qu'à la raison de
rappeler c'est là ça va se jouer pour le
rassemblement national qui est qu'à un
moment la majorité ne va pas juste
défendre sa réforme elle va envoyer aux
oppositions l'idée de est-ce que vous
avez une réforme alternative à proposer
or dans l'opinion pour beaucoup
d'électeurs finalement la réforme est un
mal nécessaire c'est sans doute pas
celle qu'il faut faire elle est mal
calibrée mais l'idée de la réforme est
et là et donc le RN va devoir encore
plus que la France insoumise pour
justifier son titre de premier opposant
expliquer ce qu'il ferait si demain il
était au pouvoir que
se passe-t-il chez nos amis américains
c'est un autre thème la semaine dernière
les autorités ont annoncé qu’un noir de
31 ans avait été tué par la police Kenan
Anderson c'est son nom enseignant et
père de famille il a été brutalement
interpellé après un banal accident de
voiture les images de l'interpellation
ont été publiées par les autorités
regardez
bien ici retourne-toi oui monsieur sur
le ventre mets-toi sur le ventre
s'il vous plaît
pas ça monsieur s'il vous plaît
aidez-moi ils essaient de me tuer
retourne-toi s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je vais utiliser mon
Taser arrête ça tout de suite arrête ça
tout de suite retourne-toi retourne-toi
où j'utilise mon Taser retourne-toi où
j'utilise mon Taser retourne-toi ou
j'utilise mon Taser je ne peux pas
attention à ton coup de coéquipier
ils essaient de me faire une George
Floyd ils essaient de me faire une
George fleur
arrête de résister s'il te plaît arrête
de résister
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
d'accord arrête
de me tuer il essaie de me tuer
[Musique]
les images évidemment pas facile très
difficile même six coups de Taser en 42
secondes alors les causes de la mort
sont toujours pas déterminées suit son
cours mais est-ce qu'on est en présence
d'une nouvelle affaire Joyce flood genre
Floyd
on est dans la continuité de la faire
Georges Floyd bien sûr il y a un vrai
vrai problème de racisme de la dans la
police américaine on le voit parce qu'il
y a pas eu que de Georges Floyd il y en
a eu beaucoup beaucoup des noirs des
jeunes noirs qui
ayant eu peur ce sont ce sont se sont
enfuis et qui du coup ont été tués sans
aucun aucune enfin sans qui aucune
coïncidence c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus structurel comme on dit
sur elle systémique il y a une toute une
génération dans la police américaine qui
est qui est raciste et qui vise qui vise
les Noirs il y a un vrai problème de
racisme on dit non anti noir dans la
police américaine et donc qui a une
nécessité indispensable de de former
enfin là il y a une vraiment j'espère
que le les auteurs autorités américaines
ont conscience de ce problème et qu'une
nouvelle génération va être mieux formée
pour pour que ces turices c'est un
problème de police Pascal ou c'est un
problème plus général de dans la société
américaine de l'histoire américaine en
général
bon il y a un problème de la police
américaine on le voit la police
américaine moi je suis chaque année aux
États-Unis en effet que vous soyez noir
ou blanc quand là vous avez affaire à la
police américaine ce qui m'est arrivé
pour une histoire de j'allais un peu
trop vite sur une autoroute en effet
vous sentez très vite qu'il ne faut pas
plaisanter il y a une forme de
brutalité
de d'usage très rapide des armes les
Colt sont sorties vous voyez pour une
histoire de dépassement de de d'image de
vitesse donc il y a là une tradition qui
est extrêmement forte vous avez vu que
parmi les les policiers qui arrêtent ce
jeune noir il y a des Noirs qui sont des
policiers donc oui il y a un racisme
dans la société américaine je veux dire
c'est pas la seule société dans lequel
le problème c'est vraiment la police les
méthodes de la police il y a un problème
de méthode de la police aux États-Unis
et la réforme est assez difficile parce
que
il faut bien nous on a une police
nationale vous voyez bon d'accord il y a
une police fédérale mais ces policiers
ce sont des policiers qui dépendent
d'autorité municipales la plupart du
temps je suis sûr que ces policiers
certainement dépendent Los Angeles
municipales de Los Angeles il y a des
traditions de police extrêmement dures
dans le sud il y a des policiers alors
là qui sont vraiment
j'allais enracinés dans une culture
raciste et à Los Angeles c'est pas la
première fois qu'il y a un problème avec
d'abord les méthodes d'interpellation de
la de la police de la police américaine
très vite en effet vous êtes brutalisé
alors là on verra dans l'enquête ce
qu'il en est ce que c'est véritablement
un George Floyd bis bon pour l'instant
il est un peu tôt de se prononcer mais
je crois qu'il y a et ça ne dépend pas
simplement envoyer du président de la
majorité au Congrès il y a véritablement
une prise de conscience nécessaire à
avoir et c'est difficile aux États-Unis
parce que il y a une culture de l'usage
de l'arme qui n'est pas du tout la même
que chez nous c'est pour les Américains
je le vois quand on vit aux États-Unis
c'est pour les Américains une liberté
l'usage de l'arbre et le problème c'est
la méthode mais j'aimerais vous montrer
quelque chose aussi Pascal se rapporte
Guardian qui nous dit que la police
californienne est deux fois plus
susceptible d'utiliser la force contre
des noirs que contre des blancs
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire moi je
pense que le problème il est bien
au-delà de la police et si rien n'a été
fait contre le racisme de la police et
qu'il y a des fondements profonds à la
remontée du racisme aux États-Unis
banane la l'idéologie
a compris que bon on allait pas prendre
le pouvoir avec cette manifestation au
Congrès et que maintenant c'est une
conquête à bas bruit c'est à dire que
maintenant il s'instille dans les
comités de quartier dans les réunions
d'écoles dans les dans les municipalités
on retire Darwin des rayons des écoles
on retire des romans qui sont trop à la
faveur de la dénonciation de l'esclavage
et petit à petit on s'installe dans la
société mais de manière très radicale et
donc il y a en ce moment une remontée
d'un racisme ordinaire puissant qui est
en train de se passer aux États-Unis
c'est voilà c'est c'est peut-être on
regarde tout ce qui se passe les
successeurs de Trump etc mais au-delà du
jeu politique qui est très visible par
derrière il y a une infiltration une une
phénomène fluide donc un effet contre
cette police qui est raciste parce que
finalement comme vous le disiez il y a
beaucoup de petites ou de grandes
municipalités qui laissent faire Bernard
vous êtes d'accord oui bien sûr les
images sont glaçantes d'abord c'est
c'est frappant mais c'est vrai que si on
élargit un tout petit peu le le champ et
au-delà de ce de ce drame on est quand
même frappé quand on regarde l'état
d'opinion en France on dit et parce qu'à
Perrino le dit souvent
on est frappé par les fractures
françaises là on a le sentiment que aux
États-Unis ce n'est plus des fractures
c'est devenu des oppositions violentes
radicales et que c'est ça se manifeste
évidemment avec des intensités
dramatiques ça se manifeste vos
événements politiques nous on a le
sentiment qu'aux États-Unis les
fractures sont devenues irrégonsiables
et ce qui faisait la force de la nation
américaine et quand même aujourd'hui
très affaiblie est-ce que vous voulez
jouer Guylaine ah moi j'adore après ça
on va faire quelque chose d'un peu plus
léger justement on va passer à la
rubrique fake news ou pas je vous donne
une information et vous me dites vous
connaissez le jeu vous me dites si c'est
vrai ou si c'est fake les suites de
l'affaire Noël le Great elle a la
Fédération Française de foot le
gouvernement a annoncé vouloir légiférer
à la suite du scandale dont vous avez
évidemment entendu parler l'offense a
Zinédine Zidane sera désormais passible
de 4 ans d'emprisonnement et de 300.000
euros d'amende l'exécutif d'y vouloir
agir et saisir contre l'impunité en
matière d'injures contre l'ancien numéro
10 des Bleus Pascal vous avez la réponse
qui a inventé cette histoire une vraie
information ou pas c'est une fausse
information on ne peut pas personnaliser
comme ça évidemment
le régime pénal c'est une fausse
information c'est ça vient de nos amis
du gorafi direction le Pérou ou les
policiers ont de l'imagination le pays
traversent actuellement une crise
politique mais les forces de l'ordre ont
décidé pendant la période des fêtes de
Noël et bien de se déguiser pour arrêter
les trafiquants de drogue ils se sont
habillés en Père Noël pour passer
inaperçu dans les quartiers de Lima et
pouvoir mieux appréhender les
délinquants fake news ou pas Bernard ça
pourrait être vrai ça pourrait être vrai
en tout cas c'est créatif comme idée
vous mettez vrai Alexandra
aucune idée mais vous pouvez pas voter
c'est vrai c'est une information qui a
été relayée dans Ouest-France opération
a permis de saisir 6000 paquets de
cocaïne retour en France on termine avec
cette information le gouvernement vient
de dévoiler son plancha simplement qui
était très attendu l'exécutif demande
français d'arrêter de se trouver
systématiquement dans la trajectoire des
balles de chasseurs un décret sera pris
en ce sens dans les semaines qui
viennent sur mon respect sera sanctionné
évidemment deux 350 euros est-ce que je
vous pose la question ça pourrait être
vrai mais c'est bien sûr faux mais ils
sont capables vu l'attachement à la
chasse à la chasse
ça pourrait être vrai restez chez vous
fake news évidemment encore du goaf il y
a les plus sérieux le nucléaire a-t-il
définitivement remporté la partie
fait-il désormais consensus en France
une loi est en tout cas actuellement
débattue par le Parlement elle vise à
simpl les procédures en ce qui concerne
la construction de nouvelles centrales
ce mercredi le sida a dit oui au
gouvernement
le projet de loi qui nous rassemble
aujourd'hui marque une nouvelle phase de
notre politique nucléaire en
introduisant un cadre d'accélération du
processus d'autorisation administrative
pour les futurs projets nucléaires je
veux vraiment insister sur ce point ce
texte ne vise pas à décider ni de la
place de l'énergie nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique français ni des détails d'un
programme de nouveaux nucléaires ni de
la politique en matière de traitement et
de recyclage des déchets ou de la R&D
Alexandra Le Figaro dans son édito cette
semaine nous dit qu'on est en train de
rattraper le temps perdu en matière de
nucléaire est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
mais en tout cas c'est le rêve
d'Emmanuel Macron ça c'est sûr et c'est
le rêve de tout le lobby nucléaire qui
d'un coup voit
la crise énergétique due à la guerre en
Ukraine et le besoin de et surtout la
crise climatique et le besoin d'obtenir
une énergie décarbonée qui voit ça comme
une aubaine donc en effet il y a en ce
moment une tentative incroyable de de
développer à marche forcée le nucléaire
l'énergie le nucléaire civil alors qu'on
voit bien que depuis des années c'est
une catastrophe tous les grands projets
qui ont été lancés ont pris du retard
coûte la peau des fesses et c'est un
vrai problème par ailleurs ça je
voudrais préciser ça le la guerre en
Ukraine a montré aussi que une centrale
nucléaire peut-être peut-être peut
devenir une arme de guerre peut-être
utiliser comme une arme de guerre donc
moi ce qui me fait quand même assez peur
c'est que toutes ces envies notamment
celle d'Emmanuel Macron de développer
plein de petites centrales nucléaires un
peu partout
c'est potentiellement très dangereux
même si en effet il y a un problème de
de de ressources d'énergie très
important mais je pense qu'il faut quand
même s'ass'étudie beaucoup plus finement
que ça
le vent en poupe en ce moment y compris
dans l'opinion c'est c'est très net
depuis plusieurs dernières années on
voit bien que parce que il est garantit
l'indépendance du pays c'est le premier
à tout qui lui est attribué par par
l'opinion tu sais moi parce qu'il est
plus accessible moins intermittent bien
sûr que des que les renouvelables
troisièmement parce qu'il est encore
considéré comme une énergie moins chère
que les autres il a regagné des places
dans l'opinion mais l'opinion ne
plébiscite pas un choix qui serait du
tout nucléaire il faut pas lire les
chiffres des études comme cela vous avez
si Français sur 10 qui sont favorables
au mix énergétique c'est-à-dire il faut
développer du renouvelable mais il faut
continuer à investir dans le nucléaire
d'ailleurs même à gauche il y a une
ligne de partage quasiment à 55 ans donc
c'est vrai que c'est une un mouvement
comme on en a peu vu dans l'opinion sur
des questions vous expliquer cette
évolution de vis-à-vis du nucléaire donc
c'est effectivement peut-être la guerre
en Ukraine les problèmes énergétique le
coup
effectivement que malgré tout d'ailleurs
on a gardé un savoir-faire français même
s'il y a les retards dont vous avez
parlé mais c'est retard d'ailleurs quand
on pose la question ils ne sont pas trop
imputés à EDF qui regardent une très
bonne image ils sont plutôt imputés au
gouvernement qui n'aurait pas pris aux
politiques qui appris les bonnes les
bonnes décisions justement vous parlez
de coût d'argent Guylaine la France
est-ce que on est vraiment en capacité
d'augmenter notre parc nucléaire quand
on voit effectivement les problèmes de
coût les problèmes d'entretien la
volonté visiblement elle est lâcher
Emmanuel Macron chez le gouvernement
mais est-ce qu'on est vraiment capable
de le faire ah oui il y a la volonté et
comme vous le disiez une opinion
vous parlez d'Emmanuel Macron
effectivement Emmanuel Macron qui
l'année dernière a annoncé dans son
discours de Belfort la construction d'un
nouveau parc nucléaire écoutez c'était
il y a tout juste un an
je souhaite que 6 EPR 2 soit construit
et que nous lançons les études sur la
construction de 8 EPR 2 additionnels
nous avons ainsi Parlier la clé pour
produire cette électricité de manière la
plus décarbonée
la plus sûre
la plus souveraine et justement d'avoir
une stratégie plurielle celle que nous
avons choisi sur la base de ces travaux
et de développer tout à la fois les
énergies renouvelables et le nucléaire
en 2017 Emmanuel Macron était élu sur la
promesse de réduire à 50% la part de
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique il y a
une conversion d'Emmanuel Macron au
nucléaire Pascal oui de manière évidente
bien sûr
c'est pas d'ailleurs le seul domaine sur
lequel il y a une conversion on a
beaucoup parlé de la retraite si vous
voulez le projet de retraite actuel il
le condamnait parce qu'en fait il était
favorable un projet de retraite qu'on
appelle systémique voilà le fameux
projet de retard
donc ce n'est pas si vous voulez mais on
désigne du doigt Macron c'est pas le
premier a changé une fois au pouvoir et
prenant conscience des contraintes du
pouvoir mais il faut se méfier là-dessus
des effets d'annonce dont le président
est assez
assez coutumier quand il dit nous parle
d'une stratégie par pallier on se
demande qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
stratégie par palier on aimerait bien
que l'élève Macron nous donne nous donne
une réponse un peu plus un peu plus
argumentée et là on voit très bien quel
que soit en effet le changement de cap
du président que une stratégie du quoi
qu'il en coûte à hauteur de 51 milliards
là on ne voit pas très bien comment le
pays serait capable à brève et même les
moyennes échéances de développer une
stratégie du quoi qu'il en coûte sur le
terrain nucléaire comment vous analysez
Alexandra cette évolution cette
conversion d'Emmanuel Macron et
nucléaire je pense que je pense qu'il y
a un problème de crédibilité du
président parce que on voit bien que
entre son premier mandat et le deuxième
quand il était durant son premier mandat
il a débit et le projet de réforme des
retraites qu'il est en train de vendre
aujourd'hui le nucléaire il avait un
objectif qui a été totalement maintenant
il prône l'inverse
un moment où il y a un problème de
crédibilité et je pense que ça ça le
contexte ça le même non plus et
d'ailleurs c'est c'est bien aussi de
tenir compte d'évoluer de tenir compte
du contexte international bien sûr mais
lui c'est un peu systématique et si vous
voulez il y a un moment où je pense que
ça donne ce qui est en train de se
passer les gens n'y comprennent plus
rien ah bon mais alors pourquoi le le
report de l'âge légal c'était considéré
comme mal il y a 3 ans pourquoi c'est
bien aujourd'hui le nucléaire alors
certes il y a eu la guerre en
Ukraine et surtout la crise climatique
crise climatique entre parenthèses qu'il
a eu qu'il n'avait pas vu venir on l'a
vu dans ses vœux à Noël qui était une
petite phrase irréelle comment aurait-on
pu prévoir enfin bref le problème c'est
que là ça fait beaucoup ça fait beaucoup
de de de changement de cap et je pense
qu'à un moment où les gens n'y
comprennent plus rien et c'est ça
explique aussi qu'il y a eu autant de
gens dans la rue hier de la pipe on le
voit d'ailleurs assez nettement dans les
enquêtes sur la personnalité d'Emmanuel
Macron avec un chiffre qui s'est inversé
quand on prend un an après 2017 et
aujourd'hui alors on n'est pas tout à
fait au un an du second mandat sur la
question de Emmanuel Macron a-t-il un
cap il y avait une majorité de Français
assez net 58 % en 2018 qui disait oui le
président un cap d'ailleurs des advers
des électeurs qui parfois étaient des
opposants Emmanuel Macron mais qui
disait on peut lui reprocher mais en
tout cas on sait où il veut aller là ce
cap est devenu moins lisible et ça
brouille un peu l'image du président
cette semaine nous avons eu les amis des
nouvelles de Jean-Michel Blanquer on a
appris que l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale est désormais
avocat dans un cabinet parisien il a
prêté serment au barreau de Paris après
avoir obtenu une agrégation en droit à
l'Université Panthéon Assas Jean-Michel
Blanquer jeune avocat donc mais ces
derniers mois d'autres anciens ministres
sont aussi reconvertis dans le privé
tout cela m'amène à la question suivante
est-ce que le métier de politique fait
encore rêver pas vraiment si on en croit
france-olivier Giesbert et Catherine
Nails étaient cette semaine dans
l'excellente émission de Public Sénat au
bonheur des livres écoutés il y a des
personnalités politiques on en rencontre
tout le temps qui serait cette
formidablement qu'avant ça c'est sûr
n'intéresse plus franchement c'est mal
payé c'est la Haute autorité sur la
transparence et le col de la suspicion
les gens n'ont pas envie qu'on leur de
pose des questions sur leur patrimoine à
10 ans leurs factures il y a 10 ans des
choses insupportables parce que
aujourd'hui une crise de la vocation
politique oui elle n'est pas nouvelle
c'est une affaire une affaire ancienne
en effet la carrière politique n'attire
plus comme elle pouvait attirer par le
passé parce que d'abord c'est devenu une
activité professionnelle dans lequel on
accumule beaucoup d'ennuis beaucoup de
difficultés la question des salaires je
sais que c'est très impopulaire
d'aborder cette question parce que
beaucoup de Français sont persuadés que
les politiques s'en les poches mais la
question des salaires est une vraie
question
brut par mois mais posez la question
pour les mères et vous verrez si
vraiment beaucoup de Français feraient
le métier que font les maires de petites
communes avec l'indemnité qui leur est
offertes donc il y a une vraie question
en effet de salaire et moi je le vois
puisque je suis professeur à Sciences Po
et que l'on a formé pendant des
décennies énormément de de politique la
carrière politique depuis environ 15 20
ans n'attire plus et n'attire plus les
meilleurs ce qui est une véritable
préoccupation quand j'ai commencé à
enseigner les meilleurs c'était pour
évident qu'il soit de gauche de droite
ou d'ailleurs c'était l'intérêt général
la carrière politique etc aujourd'hui ça
n'est plus du tout le cas c'est le privé
les ONG les organisations
internationales et le politique arrive
en queue
pose un problème parce que ça renforce
la crise
sur le constat vous pouvez partager tout
ce constat ici qui a une crise de la
vocation politique on viendra ensuite
peut-être aux raisons vous parlez des
salaires mais il y a peut-être d'autres
saisons aussi aujourd'hui si vous êtes
ambitieuse c'est vrai très ambitieux
c'est pas forcément la politique qui
vous intéresse vous n'avez plus le
pouvoir hein puisque maintenant de toute
façon il y a plus d'argent à dépenser il
y a des déficits donc vous avez des
emmerdes devant vous vous avez la Haute
Autorité de Sarah enfin c'est plus très
amusant vous pouvez plus cumuler donc
vous avez pu le pouvoir et vous avez pas
l'argent vous avez encore moins qu'avant
parce que la politique ça a toujours
attiré bon les gens qui avaient des
convictions l'intérêt général mais
c'était aussi un instant social oui il
suffit de regarder le profil des députés
des des ministres encore aujourd'hui
c'est des gens qui sont souvent partis
de pas grand chose et qui ont atteint un
statut social mais il y avait ou 30 ans
vous étiez président d'une société
directeur d'une société ou ministre ou
député vous étiez un peu près au même
rang social vous aviez la même résidence
secondaire vous y allez même dîners vous
étiez dans la il y a autant de légions
d'honneur etc aujourd'hui
celui qui est patron ou qui a des
entreprises c'est lui qui a la belle
maison c'est lui qui peut arroser etc
à 50 quoi il y a un gap énorme je vais
sortir exceptionnellement de la
neutralité du sondeur moi il faut il
faut arrêter avec le politique bashing
voilà il y a évidemment des choses à
critiquer quand il faut à condamner mais
on a besoin des politiques on a besoin
des politiques on a besoin d'engagement
politique à tous les niveaux d'ailleurs
militants élus et le travail de
politique de responsable politique est
un travail qui demande vous l'avez
évoqué des contraintes de l'engagement
que parfois en caricature un peu ça
c'est le premier point il y a le sujet
de la rémunération et qui s'est posé
alors difficilement avec la question du
cumul parce qu'on a confondu assez vite
cumule des mandats et cumul de
rémunération mais c'est un vrai sujet il
y a l'autre question qui n'est pas
complètement rayée qui est la question
ça fait quoi ce qui vient de se passer
pour Jean-Michel Blanquer qui est la
question des passerelles si on veut que
la politique ne pas réserver aux
apparatifs ou comme on dit aux techno il
faut que les passerelles soient
encadrées réglementés évidemment mais
qu'elle puisse avoir lieu parce que
sinon ça appauvrit la vie politique de
ne pas avoir des gens qui sont en phase
pendant 3 ans 5 ans 10 ans avec la
société civile Alexandra vous j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a un consensus sur
ce plateau autour de la rémunération un
député j'ai dit gagne 8231 euros brut
par mois est-ce qu'il faut augmenter nos
élus certainement pas non non mais ce
que ce que je alors à part les maires
vous avez raison peut-être eux oui parce
que les moments
les mains dans le cambouis ils s'en
prennent plein la figure parce que c'est
souvent c'est des endroits où tout le
monde se connaît il suffit d'une fin
bref les mères c'est autre chose les
députés non je suis désolé 8000 et
quelques euros par mois ça suffit
amplement c'est même bien plus que ce
que beaucoup de gens c'est pas un
problème de rémunération
dans ce que je pense et que finalement
je trouve que c'est plutôt sain ce qui
est en train de se passer parce que
pendant longtemps
les politiques c'est de monter dans
l'échelle politique c'était acquérir un
statut social avoir avec tous les
avantages qui vont avec une voiture de
fonction une secrétaire etc c'était
représenté quelqu'un c'était avoir du
pouvoir
et c'est pas ça finalement la politique
je pense que maintenant ceux qui
s'engagent en politique ce sont des gens
qui ne cherchent pas forcément à voir
une voiture avec chauffeur à avoir à
gagner des milles et descents mais qui
ont des vrais convictions et je pense
notamment à la jeune génération qui est
qui est alors qui est très en révolte
pour l'instant et notamment sur la crise
climatique mais ça peut s'élargir autre
chose et je pense que ce sont des gens
qui veulent réellement aller sur le
terrain et qui savent qu'il y a beaucoup
de coups à prendre mais ils sont prêts à
les prendre ils savent qu'il y a pas
beaucoup d'argent c'est pas là où ils
vont devenir milliardaire il faut plutôt
aller dans le privé mais ils y sont
prêts et du coup je trouve que ça on va
voir on verra le résultat
salutaire n'exagérons pas je suis
d'accord qu'il en politique bashing qui
est compliqué mais je pense que c'est un
moment je pense qu'il y a le ras-le-bol
d'une génération qui notamment d'hommes
parce que très masculine qui était
heureuse d'avoir du pouvoir et qui était
heureuse qui jouissait d'exercer ce
pouvoir et que maintenant cette
génération est en train de de partir et
que c'est plus et qu'une nouvelle
génération voit la politique non pas
pour acquérir un statut social mais pour
essayer de faire changer les choses et
ça je trouve ça plutôt simple quel est
le rôle alors on fait pas de politique
de politique bashing mais peut-être de
sur les réseaux sociaux on va pas faire
du réseau social bashing mais est-ce que
les réseaux sociaux ont changé quelque
chose aussi à cette approche je sais pas
est-ce que quelle aurait été la carrière
d'un de Gaulle d'un Mitterrand d'un
Giscard a l'air des réseaux sociaux
parce que
en effet les réseaux sociaux donnent aux
hommes politiques et aux femmes
politiques
j'allais dire une transparence qui
n'existait pas auparavant le moindre de
leur fils et gestes des éventuels
sottises nous en disons tous qui disent
et répercuté ça prend une ampleur
littéralement phénoménale vous êtes
exposé en permanence au regard de tous
ça c'est radicalement nouveau alors que
la politique là aussi je vais être très
impopulaire la politique a besoin d'un
minimum de secrets
lisez lisez Machiavel on n'a pas besoin
on ne peut pas imaginer une activité
publique totalement transparente ça
c'est une histoire j'allais dire pour
les bisounours la politique a besoin
d'une certaine part de secret et c'est
vrai que les les réseaux sociaux là ont
changé radicalement la donne pour le
meilleur parfois pour le pire le plus
souvent vous êtes d'accord Mitterrand a
l'air des réseaux sociaux ça donne quoi
je crois aux forces de l'esprit
tôt qu'il avait une fille bon est-ce que
serait vraiment changé le cours de
l'histoire mais je trouve que dit
Alexandra très intéressant parce que
est-ce que effectivement maintenant on
voit que les jeunes veulent avoir une
activité qui est du sens il y a 250000
jeunes qui très formés qui ont quitté
les grandes entreprises pour rentrer
dans l'artisanat ça veut quand même dire
quelque chose de la société donc est-ce
que ces jeunes ont envie de s'engager en
politique pour faire des choses utiles
etc moi je trouve que c'est une bonne
piste mais je pense qu'à ce moment-là
faudra changer les institutions parce
que aussi un des dégoûts de la politique
c'est qu'il y a une personne qui décide
de tout et après vous avez des
courtisans même au gouvernement donc
c'est pas très excitant je vous donne la
parole dans exactement 10 secondes
Ghislaine parce que comme chaque semaine
on termine l'émission par un top flop je
vous pose à chacun une question simple
quelle personnalité a marqué l'actualité
en bien ou en mal Ghislaine vous
commencez votre top votre flop ah non
moi j'ai que des tops aujourd'hui j'ai
voulu être optimiste donc alors j'ai
adoré l'appel des des
des millionnaires adavos qui disent ben
faites nous payer c'est vrai en disant
notre capital augmenter de 50% mais
servez-vous allez-y et moi je dis donc
allez les riches voilà pour une fois
c'est quand même sympathique et le
deuxième c'est Denis cognaud qui a écrit
un livre un peu universitaire qui
s'appelle un empire bon marché et c'est
sur l'histoire de la colonisation
française avec des comparaisons avec les
autres colonisations et je trouve ça
extrêmement intéressant parce que c'est
la première fois qu'un universitaire où
il est très gradé des professeurs dans
tous les endroits un peu intéressants
etc à l'École d'économie de Paris etc et
il prend les chiffres combien étaient
payés les fonctionnaires combien on a
investi où on a invité où est-ce qu'on a
fait des trains est-ce que c'était pour
la population locale où c'était pour les
exportateurs français et c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est pas
idéologisé et on voit vraiment que la
colonisation a profité un très petit
nombre double top Bernard vous c'est un
top et un flop alors un top pour l'unité
syndicale pas seulement parce que il y a
le succès de la mobilisation on l'a dit
reconnu mais aussi parce que les
syndicats ont montré leur utilité dans
la capacité à encadrer ces
manifestations et à faire on verra si ça
continue qu'il n'y ait pas qu'il n'y ait
pas d'incident comme on avait connu
depuis plusieurs manifestations donc les
corps intermédiaires notamment les
syndicats les organisations
professionnelles c'est
utile et un flop il y a un flop c'est le
parti socialiste le Parti socialiste qui
plusieurs heures après avoir clos ces
bureaux de vote n'est toujours pas
capable de donner le vainqueur et les
deux prétendants Olivier Faure et
Nicolas meilleur Rossignol se
revendiquent un cœur donc après la coco
et pour la droite on va voir la
commission de recollement bien connue
des spécialistes du parti réaliser plus
les solférinologues puisque le PS a
démissionné Alexandra vous part on part
sur l'international avec vous je crois
oui oui moi le top je continue à je suis
bouleversée parce qu'il se passe en Iran
et et ce peuple qui se qui se bat avec
les avec le peu de moyens d'anti dispose
au risque de d'être exécuté donc je
pense soutien absolu au peuple iranien
et le flop c'est c'est les talibans qui
qui en murent
vivent les femmes les jeunes filles les
enfants et ça c'est absolument terrible
et ce qui est terrible c'est que sur
l'Iran comme sur l'Afghanistan il y a
quasiment aucun levier pour essayer de
faire cesser cette situation Pascal
votre top votre blog en France dans le
cadre de l'Hexagone
le top si vous voulez on en a parlé
beaucoup de la grande difficulté du
pouvoir sur cette affaire des retraites
à communiquer je crois qu'il y a un
échec majeur dites-nous ce que j'ai
jamais fait un pouvoir aussi mal
communiqué sur une réforme qui on peut
en discuter mais qui n'est pas un pur
scandale il suffit de regarder les
autres pays européens autour de nous on
Gabriel exceptionnalité française donc
je trouve que dans ce paysage dévasté
Gabriel Attal ce jeune ministre sentir
plutôt mieux que les autres sur le
terrain pédagogique
la secrétaire général des de d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts qui accumuler en
quelques jours elle nous a expliqué que
au fond de l'Assemblée nationale devait
venir
et d'autre part c'est interrogé
également sur la nécessité de
milliardaires merci Pascal net au coeur
de la primaire merci beaucoup c'est la
fin de cette émission merci à vous
quatre de l'avoir participé merci à vous
derrière votre écran mais chuchote dans
l'oreillette que vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreux à nous regarder à nous
revoir en replay et en podcast merci à
vous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
même jour même heure et même endroit bye
bye
[Musique]